إنها قرع طبول الثورة
وقرع بايرويت وعبر لبنان لليوم
الرابع على التوالي ، استمرت الاحتجاجات
كل يوم أكبر من اليوم
السابق للجو المبتهج ، لكن
المظالم الأساسية الغضب من
الاقتصاد المتعثر والفساد الرسمي
والخدمات الأساسية بالكاد تعمل
يوسف البالغ من العمر خمس سنوات  يعاني من
مرض وراثي ، والده إبراهيم
، جندي سابق ،
لا يستطيع العثور على عمل ، لا يستطيع تحمل تكاليف
علاج يوسف مع زوجته فرح ،
حاولوا مغادرة البلاد على متن قارب مع
لاجئين سوريين إلى تركيا ، أعلم قليلاً
أننا دفعنا 8000 يورو يقول  إبراهيم ، لقد بعنا
سيارتنا دراجتي النارية على أمل أن
نجد شيئًا أفضل خارج القارب الذي
غرق ، لقد نجوا بصعوبة ، لقد
غرقنا تقريبًا عندما كان يبلغ من العمر 8 أشهر.يقول
إبراهيم إننا نجازف بحياته هربًا من
هذا البلد المثير للاشمئزاز.
من الاقتصاد
هناك استياء عميق تجاه
النخبة السياسية والتجارية في لبنان كما
كانوا  أخذ الكثير من المال لمدة ست
سنوات ، هناك بعض الأشخاص
يسرقونهم ،
ولكن في النهاية سيقول الناس لا في
الوقت الحالي ، يبدو النسيج الذي هو لبنان وكأنه
واحد من المتظاهرين وحدهم الغضب
والغضب من النظام السياسي الذي
استخدم الانقسامات الطائفية لما يقرب من 80 عامًا
لتفكيكها
، يتصاعد الضغط من الشارع ، وفي غضون أيام فقط
مع ظهور النتائج مرارًا وتكرارًا ،
تراجعت الحكومة هنا ، وألغت
ضريبة whatsapp التي وعدت بها بعدم فرض المزيد من
الضرائب على المواطنين العاديين ولم
تتخلَّ عن فكرة ميزانية التقشف
أيا من هذه الخطوات  لكن كان له تأثير كبير
على هذه الاحتجاجات